[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne crois pas qu'il existe en langue
française d'ouvrage compara à
l'Encyclopédie du renseignement et des
services secrets que Jacques beau publie
chez lavosel ce très sérieux et très
technique précis d'espionnage rédigé par
un officier supérieur de l'armée suisse
plonge le lecteur dans un étrange et
assez fascinant univers parallèle dont
la première caractéristique est qu'il
concerne tous les pays et ce que nous en
imaginons par les films et par les
romans semble très éloigné de la
réalité il est ici question
d'aéronautique et de politique de
physique et de relations humaines oui un
véritable monde à côté du autre à notre
insu à notre service paraît-il il y a là
les codes cryptographique qui permettent
de brouiller ou de déchiffrer les
messages carré de polibe table de vign
vert les taupes célèbres Gunter
Guillaume Kim Philby et ceux qui ont
parlé comme David Cromwell alias John
leCarré on apprend que les drones sont
des avions de reconnaissance sans pilote
qu'une information peut-être
déclassifiée le budget l'organisation
des centrales des principaux pays sont
ici détaillés les systèmes de radar et
de camouflage comment on recrute un
agent le rôle des femmes tout cela
est-il vrai oui
[Musique]
apparemment